hello there citizens of the reject Nation we
are going to watch House of the Dragon episode
8 today John how are you I'm just giddy with
Glee you you sir how's Greg I'm feeling good
team Allison right guys oh yeah everyone in the
comments keeps chanting it team team Allison
put on that green light that's what we're all
talking about here at the reject nation is how
we're all back in teamhouse that's right dude
you know I hope renira dies this episode of
the UK audience picks up on sarcasm ladies and
gentlemen leave a like that would be very much
appreciated breathe fire onto that subscribe
button to get notified when our reaction for
the next episode is up also full interaction
watch along through sync up with your own copy
for hotd available for a super sexy rejects
over at our Patron page and cover a bunch of
shows over there exclusively for super sexy
rejects lastly the team of prepper thank you
guys for the hustle and bustle for helping
us at the stuff down let's get into action
my God and yet I have seen Blood Fever overcome
men half his age I will not suffer the talk of
crows in my house payment wow drift Mark Is Mine
by All rights and one I should like your support I
iron
from the queen I don't want
Corliss to die I like Corliss
wow what a shot
yes
oh he's got his he had his sneaking robe on
he looks so happy
come ruin his good mood he
means to cool into question
Venom spread so far those vipers
rule in my father's name father
it's got to be like a pile of sand now
yeah just like uh he's become one with
like a wall it's a petrified tree root with
a crown on it Guillermo del Toro creature
Amato has arisen that requires your attention
it is you need to wait America Grace
it's about the prince there's been a delicate
situation in his Apartments what did he do
oh see the cobwebs on it
wow that's poor guy
still have like Alzheimer's maybe it seems like
the sea snake has taken a grave
wound in battle in Step stones
the big call is for Lauren's successor
someone we wish to introduce you to
such great like underlying nuances in
the scene two performances this is agon
oh God and this is viserys
that that is his name Fit For A King
hi oh
they're like keeping him sick I was just about
to ask that yeah it was fetching a princess
wine and I put it on his table when I turned I
didn't see him I asked him to stop you guys God
wow
what would I worry about the butt
that's what others might believe
you're alone with the prince were you not yes
and no one else thought to happen between the
two of you oh Jesus Jesus you might think
you're trying to massage the prince or worse
that you're the sort of girl that might have
enticed him in the first place you know what
happens to girls like that hey how was that
dream about anything another one to anyone oh
it's supposed to be certain
it's at the same drink they gave renera yeah
I think so at least they're just straight up
poisoned yeah I was like I hope it's the plan
BT what is it what is it what is it what is it
that's all you can save yourself there's something
happened oh my God it's so Fury shame on your wife
on me how can you keep carrying on like there's a
special on a day like today why what is it today
nothing's changed the last six
years not not a King's Landing
I've done everything you've asked me to
and I try so try so hard but it will never
be enough for you or father have you seen
Diana she's supposed to dress the children
oh oh I guess that's our answer yeah
it's been so long since we were granted
the joy of your presence oh still fresh
this day him paddled on look of the poppy well
the high Towers warmed us through whenever if you
would see him without lined with suffering
suffering I have no doubt it was an act of
the purest Mercy which authority will sit in
Judgment of my son's claim on his own inheritance
held in this room bye mic drop
foreign
nephews if you come to train he turned
into crisping Glover he did in a big
place like a whole other guy literally
had to question like is that crisping
I've always wanted to be on Game of Thrones
to your son you may not
believe it to be true but I did
I did not order his death nor was I complicit
in it I swear this to you technically telling
the truth I mean you can let her know no you
should get yeah it would be a terrible idea
back Luke's claim and let us betray the Lena's
children to mine a generous offer or adjustment
it does not matter
she's so good walking with me all you like but
tomorrow the high Towers land their first blue
they force you to your knees and I'm a standalone
out you've got no allies The Song of Ice and Fire
do you see it
it was our duty to hold the realm
United against a common firm
and naming the air you divided the Rock
another burden is a heavy one
especially when everyone hates you
it's defined your whole existence
Allison doesn't even sleep in
the same room no I guess not
I mean she probably only stops
it on it like once in a while now
God she really is becoming very desperate huh
I want to have supper after
ah tonight all of my family
to dine together it's forever mission to
resolve family Trump tonight there will be peace
we'll fix it all tonight
whoa damn that is insane makeup he is gaunt
as hand I speak with the king's voice on this
and all other matters
living out as fantasy I Am Lord callis's closest
kin his own blood the true and impeachable blood
of house valarian runs through my veins as it
does in my sons The Offspring of Lenor valarian
he would not be so bold as to supplant his
rightful Heir now you only speak for yourself and
for your own ambition you'll have chance to make
your own petition princess rhaenyra do serve him
in the courtesy of allowing kids to be heard oh
my God what do you know of alarion blood princess
I could cut my paint and show it to you oh I place
the continuation of the survival
of my house and my line above all
that's a compelling ass argument I will start by
reminding the court that nearly 20 years ago in
this favor oh my God he lives my man oh kingless
series walking the done hero King King angels
I'm the first men lord of the Seven
Kingdoms and protector it's [__] [__]
go stand up for her come on viserys
you got one more good speech in you
this poor guy it's just breaks my
heart how hard he tries this is
the saddest character in the entire game
of thrones universe Phantom of the Opera
your grace
come on Rocky
oh this messed up shows game
you guys are one sick family but there's love
oh
then he dies I will die upon the throne
was having my husband's will that driftmark
pass through soleno to his trueborn
son as a matter of fact the princess
rhaenyra has just informed me of her desire
to marry her sons Jason Luke to Lord call us
proposal to which I heartily agree oh my God I
have I reaffirm princess Ceres of house valarian
there to drift mark the driftwood's throne
wow what a shot what is no true valerian
serious is my trueborn grandson do you
know more than the Second Son of driftmark
oh man my house survived the doom
and a thousand tribulations besides
the account of this
head hahaha don't make the
accusation our children are bastards
is
oh man
huh
boy oh damn love your tongue
for that whoa oh wow whoa
tongue
Valerian steals Sharp
everyone needs to calm down guys this is
the most extreme chess game I have the
confidence Damon has I want everyone to know
that yep gonna be the first to wave your sword
a little bit holy crap that is gnarly haunting
it is your luck to look upon the face of death
I feel bad for her she's
had a really shitty life man
damn and yet she maintains
such composure it's insane
now that this happened Laura
Corliss has to pull through
there's some amazing composition in
this shot in this episode unlike the
other episodes terribly shot episodes shaky cam
can't see any of the production values too dark
I like the nighttime episode
how the ACT is done I assume at least
in principle but God the faces most
dear to me in all the world you've grown
so distant from each other in years past
wow
oh my God that's incredible I wish
you'd see me I am who may not it seems
walk for much longer among you
your feelings in our hearts I'm trying man I
wish to raise my cup to her grace the queen
I must admit that no one has stood more
loyally by his side than his Good Wife she
has tended to him with a failing devotion
love honor and for that she has my gratitude
fair enough we have more in
common than we sometimes allow
I raise my cup to you
guys
why can't you all just get along you'll make a
fine Queen wow oh I regret the disappointment
here soon to suffer never wish to know what it
is to be well satisfied all you have to do is ask
weary continuity there
oh damn he was ready
ah how to Prince aegon and Prince aymond
we have not seen each other in years but
I have fond memories of our shared youth yeah
really I hope we may not be friends and allies
do you and your family's good health dear uncles
there's a bit of a rocky road up until now
you don't always see eye to eye to you as well
oh geez
you know what it's like to
be satisfied on the floor
hmm
I don't trust any good things that happen
no something Terrible's gonna go down
he's gonna pass wow
oh
use the last of his strength
to try to do a loving Act
ah the big wow
final tribute to these three strong
boy I dare you to say that again why
it was only a compliment do you not think
Yourself Strong what are you guys doing
for these people I was merely expressing
how proud I am of my family mother
I invented this game
it's best I think if we go back to Dragonstone
oh they're really friendly
oh what snap
what are you doing man
I wanted for spies yeah
Prince open second
take him back it's the cold
wow this is you you are
you are wow I understand Mikey
's on the fire and ice
foreign goddamn
got [__] to talk about
oh
heaviest family reunion in the realm
all right so I think what happened
here at the very end and please
feel free to clear up without possibly
spoiling the future of the show I believe
he was taught he thought he was talking
to rhenera because she asked him earlier
um when he when she was in bed yeah about the
song of ice and asking if he believes it's true
yeah and he's saying you want to know if it's
true so and and in that scene he thought Allison
came to him yeah so I think he's just getting
confused so it's like kind of a flip root here
and then because because Allison is not supposed
to know about the prince that was promised that
is a secret thing that's passed on in the in the
blade of that can only be to the a Targaryen or
one who inherits I believe that's that's how the
rules go right um what are the rules of the Zora
high so I but I believe that's what that's what
it is so and it was aegon the Conqueror who had
the prophecy yes and I think she's getting
confused out of the center right now yeah
yeah and I and I feel like Allison is now
interpreting it to mean a different thing
yeah because I don't because Allison shouldn't
know about that no and because that's why she
was very confused and she was even sitting
in the scene right she was even saying like
what the hell are you talking about serious
so unite what now I feel like this
misunderstanding song of what is going
to lead to her not accepting how things move
forward now sure and that she thinks that for
Sarah's I could be way off but what I do
know is Allison shouldn't know about that
and so I feel like she's thinking that viserys is
saying that aegon's the one and that's and that's
also who Ellison is the one Allison's always
been telling aegon you were supposed to be the
rightful error okay you're supposed to be the one
who actually go up there and this is coming off of
the heels of Allison accepting that rhaenery could
be Queen and now I think it's all going to kind of
backfire undo all of this yeah yeah oh that's
that's happening I'm pretty sure that's what's
going on yeah because I was like why would he be
talking to her about that and then I I played it
back a tiny bit and he said I didn't catch it at
first but he said you wanted to know and I was
like oh okay yeah I definitely think he's talking
to an Era oh damn what what an uneasy Grim note
to end on yeah but it's already a stark that's
the prince of his promise don't forget yeah it's
true it's like she's the one who used to play
King like that upset people well I think the
um if I'm not mistaken that that print because
that's it's with the whole Lord of Light Pro
um religious system whatever you want to call
it uh revolves around is this prophecy and
I think Prince is I don't think it was
gender specific because from Valerian okay
heavy spoilers did it like a really great
Paul they did a great you guys know better
he did he did a great video just the other day
um going over um going over the children's one
is fresh in my mind and so yeah would be great if
we just watch that right now and take a break yeah
with all that information yeah yeah it's a great
it's a great video it is it's actually a really
wonderful Theory video that could help explain
why Arya was the one to ultimately take down the
night King okay based off of an encounter that
happened in the last episode when she did Slash
um not Danny uh renera so it's a really it's
a really really well constructed video but
yeah uh there's nothing no no this is covered in
that video so I'm like oh wow this is not it's
totally unexpected of me uh but yeah let's see
what the future holds but I feel like this this
ending scene obviously to end on it has to have
some massive implications of Direction because
they're like there's no way of the freaking
Allison to Renee she's gonna be like this will
be buzzing away episode eight things are gonna
be just fine and everyone's gonna accept what's
going on yeah yeah so shouts out to the king of
the hotd breakdowns right now um so now let's
backtrack let's go over the episode because
this was a wonderful episode uh again they
knocked it out of the park with introducing I
already forgot his name it's it's not I think
there's some baymen or something yeah something
like that but for a second he also named Eamon
wouldn't hurt George RR Martin just change
it up a little bit oh yeah change it up just
a tiny bit more please and Elena's daughter is
named after her I think so like you know so much
crossover yeah some of the names get confusing
but like introducing him and then seeing what
the repercussions were of of what the debate would
become and then what It ultimately culminated into
and I don't know I thought viserys died like
three times and so maybe he's still alive I
feel like I feel like's gonna outlive that baby
deserves at this point that's the subversion of
this show the original Game of Thrones series was
like we're gonna kill all kinds of characters you
wouldn't expect and this show is just we're
gonna keep this one guy alive way longer than
you could ever expect it's gonna evolve into the
future it's gonna evolve into the Futurama yes
maesters are just gonna wheel
him in on a tray full of milk
of the poppy like let him die just love dogs
400 years old everyone he can't speak anymore he
just blinks with his one good eye yeah if this is
a send-off like what a performance it looks like
he's it sure comes across them but I just don't
know and I feel like it would be an opportune
time to have him be dead or or maybe they'll
make him like uh brain dead but like yeah because
now he can't clarify any of this and I feel like
dramatically that will be the barrier and that
will be the kind of the thing that will allow him
to slip off this coil is like oh there's a there's
a way that you can uh you know after you've said
the thing to the wrong person that you shouldn't
say you know there's no way you can you know
try and smooth this over again yeah you know
and especially with no means to clarify I feel
like that will light the Powder Keg that has
been brewing this whole season I mean all he's
been trying to do and it's and if I if I am to
interpret what just happened here at the very end
uh that he is indeed dead is with his pacifistic
ways has been just trying to keep the peace and
try to keep everyone back in like everyone it's
all family and blood and whatever and everyone
here just really looks like the politics of it all
and he's and as king he's the only one who's like
we can't forget so a H what have you got you
were my favorite people in the world here with
me tonight put down your penny difference like
he's using his last moments to try to just end
all quarrels um amidst inside this and like
that moment when he showed up in the middle
of because I was like let's face it Raymond I
think it's his name he was winning you know as
much as I love Rainier I'm like I think this
guy I easily has to claim to drift please give
it to this guy well I mean I thought again even
coreless was like people don't remember blood
they remember names and and the last episode
I think yeah yeah and it's a compelling debate
and as much as at the you know as much as
I appreciate what he's saying and in some
ways I could you know kind of get on board
with that in other ways I'm like well given
I don't know it's fascinating to watch
as people dance on ceremony and all the
this show makes a really great display and it
exists in every government Society culture but
yeah like the ways in which people ignore the
truth in favor of the structures we have set in
place and agree upon and yeah that whole thing
about blood versus it's like I I felt so much
for what Corliss was saying even in rhenice's uh
you know protest at that point about yeah it's
the name that counts I will be remembered if my
name continues but I don't know I mean there is
something fundamental and Elemental about blood
and I feel like that's one of those things that
will come down like I bet every viewer probably
agrees differently and here yeah like I thought
he made a very compelling argument and there
was only one who's compelling argument was oh
so yeah I think that uh it was it's just because
you don't want necessarily narrow to lose but
you know especially when it cuts back to
rainey's uh when she's looking at vaman's
half decapitated uh that I'm like oh man I feel
so bad for her I was so caught up in the moment
yeah and then even when he shows up you know
like she thought she had a a chance to win and
then of course when visera shows up it's like this
is the defeat right there like just the this oh
this overwhelming presence just takes over yeah
the room and of course the respect of hierarchy
and then the one guy who stands up to it all with
the truth is cut down permanently silenced yeah
he could handle it better a yes I mean he he knew
he made his choice you know clearly waited to say
it he clearly death in that moment yeah I think
is I think a lot of the performances always have
such great underlying like weight behind what
they're all really communicating even sometimes
when you're just talking politics you could see
like right away in that first scene when uh renera
and Damon Unite with viserys and how he's can't
deal with the uncomfortableness of this situation
whether he can't face his brother and you can
imagine all kinds of things going on underneath
Damon of I haven't been there with my brother this
is kind of painful for me to see viserys like this
and then renera is you know she went there for
political purpose and then it's becoming about
family now like I don't know I want you to be
our grandson you know like there's so much other
other other things going on underneath the
surface and I think that's what's so great
about the writing packed with the acting all in
one yeah they all do that so well even the whole
debate scene too so even when they're exchanging
like this show is like the master at exchanging
looks yeah so when they're even when they're
exchanging looks of Raymond and Damon and then
they just both know you know like when he eggs
them on like just say it and they're making a
choice right there and Raymond's like once I
say this yeah I'm dead especially yeah I've
lost I I I've watched systematically through
this conversation as my claim is being ignored
and written over so yeah like I best best go out
with honor but yeah exactly in his perception he's
dying with honor yeah and so I think that's kind
of great and what an impact to make in one episode
sure hasn't been in any other episodes right
like I don't want to call them being another
episode not prominently like maybe a little bit
in like a previous one or two but yeah like this
is definitely he is a character this episode if he
has shown up who's the actor who plays of service
Patty considine fantastic yeah just uh yeah
you're gonna start off very charismatic and you
have a lot of dialogue and we're gonna let you
like deteriorate over the course of several
episodes I bet that's a fascinating Journey
for an actor because yeah I mean not only do you
have all these physical things happening to you
but you also have to really live a harsh and long
life on screen and then yeah like check back in
often years later each time and he's always felt
so consistent and it always feels no matter how
long the jump this is like six years of a jump but
each time it you can feel the in-between moments
just due to the richness of his performance and
yeah in an episode like this I imagine it's got
to be a lot on an actor because you know like
the scenes have to flow but you don't want to
be sitting there thinking about you know how long
am I pausing and things like that instead of like
to play somebody in this completely sickly State
who is you know the you of breath and speech is
you know immense effort enough like he really
sells it in a way that's not you know garish
it's just really natural and really affecting and
he's so like it's so sad it's weird it's like you
root for him but but like he's so Earnest
and sad yeah kind of always I didn't even
hear his display of strength and his display
of um you know Authority is sad is mournful
and uh yeah I don't know I like I I can't think
of I'm sure there are other examples of it but
but you know like this the performance really does
stand out for that because yeah I mean he's he's
presented to you in this position yeah like you
said of being very charismatic but you also have
so many reasons to suspect that that he's just
not made for this world and somehow he's stuck
it out but he's been punished so heavily by the
circumstances that it feels like he's still lived
this tragic life even though he's technically you
know kind of won in a lot of ways yeah you know oh
a thousand percent yeah and like the again all
the yeah little micro little expressions and to
play those through you know dementia and you know
ailing physical state and all that stuff you know
Kudos well I love I love the performances here
from uh Emma Darcy and Olivia Cook because
they they carry on the childhood that we saw the
the former actors portray and that's something
that always resonates and especially in this
episode when they had a chance to kind of soften
up and you know remind get a reminder of you know
we weren't always like this and we were both kind
of put in positions we didn't ask for and here
we are now yeah you know deal with a lot of crap
that was thrusted us and a lot of things got taken
much more serious once we became mothers you know
so to have these moments of just um it's nice to
give them some soft tender moments before [__]
gets terrible again because you know it's going
to it I I really love the harmony between the
writing and the acting because yeah like the the
writing is very rich and the writing acknowledges
the surface levels and then the acting often has
to convey so much contrast underneath and it was
refreshing it was a fascinating scene that dinner
scene because it's like you watch as the adults
or at least you know raniera and Allison and
you know viserys between them but you know you
you watch them yeah come past all the rigmarole
and all the [__] into what feels like a very
genuine moment as you're watching the kids do
like the Confederation the future Generations do
the complete inverse where it's like well okay all
everyone all the adults in the rumor are telling
us we got to do this charades so we're gonna do
it in the least uh you know genuine way possible
and we're only going to drive our wedges further
how come Eamon turned into like a 30 year old man
and he's I had to I had to do a double take
because they also like switched physiques too
whereas like aegon used to be like the lanky
long hair and now he's you know a bit stockier
and then yeah Eamonn is just like he just yeah
looks like he's a completely different human
who emerged from the depths of some dark pit
you know and yeah he's just sitting there just
like I eyeballing everybody but I also like how
there seems to be a tad bit of mirroring between
um him and Damon mm-hmm it's I loved when they
faced off in that moment that brief moment
like even Damon seems to kind of get who he is
sure yeah yeah absolutely it even smirks about
it after Eamon walks away yeah eamon's scary
he's terrifying it seems like since that night
it shows so good at the time I think that's
why the time jumps are so good because a lot
of times whatever the ending point is of the
show of the episode the time Jump is like and
here is how they all change because of that
day yeah I know yeah hearing the effects of
that down the line yeah like I think that's
just so wonderfully constructed because
you know you had a version of Eamon as a child
who was like a little bit cheapish Yeah and then
he was trying to find strength and courage and was
bullied and the pig and God then when he got his
when he got vegar and he got his eye slashed
it's like and he had he had a very specific
cold look at the very end that with the little boy
and I'm like Zach this adult actor that's the same
exact look you know it just and it seems like he
just you can feel this sense that he is fantasized
about killing the one who took his eye for so long
yes every day for these past six years and and to
the contrast again between that moment when they
have the confrontation over his eye and he makes
that realization of like okay like how I behave
here affects my mother and could have serious you
know repercussions for her and now here he seems
to be headed in the opposite direction and seems
to be you know kind of shedding you know he's a
bit older and he's gotta greed like [__] so you
know yeah the the the lines of like pageantry and
and putting up faces or precious thin especially
with those two like the two uh Eamonn and uh and
aegon like I love the aegon's just like smirking
it like he's he seems to have just maintained
the like I don't really take much of anything
seriously kind of attitude and yeah eamon's just
been stewing and and probably is going to become
a very harsh and ruthless character kids became
a lot more interesting this episode yeah and I
mean it's it's funny it's it's a fascinating tap
it's it's again a testament to how well they're
able to weave all these Stakes because you feel
for renero's kids and you kind of feel they they
have obviously like an underdogish quality because
you know it's a very thin line between the truth
and what protects them and then um you know you
have their claim on driftmark which is actively
kind of corroding and erasing you know like a a
a strong and honorable family name and it's not
really their fault but also you know they are in
a kind of messed up situation that they will then
benefit from and then you have uh aymond and aegon
who are you know clearly aware of what should have
been like uh like all the yeah all the colliding
Stakes make everything so tense but also like
vital uh you know in a way well I mean they killed
that woman and the other thing too is they killed
that woman at the beginning yeah yeah and and I
forget her name whoever the former brothel yeah
um I completely forget her name but they tease it
at the end she had a spy and there's like a maid
and she was there to deliver the drink yeah that
would kill her and I'm like what that does I guess
from one perspective is that the queen Allison
is the one who covered up something egregious
like it's like in this world like it's not
really surprising that Allison would do that
I guess I'm I'm a little I wouldn't know what I'm
saying is I'm disconnected from how the people
at King's Landing would respond to that to
learning of the information of what the queen
I don't know I guess anything of but it's like
any kind of accusation is just a crime is treason
but yeah you I I I'm not sure what to make of
what's to become of that though yeah yeah yeah
yeah what what game is is Damon's former flame
running in keeping track of all this and what
what would be the further repercussions of having
that information that aegon assaulted that woman
and then and then uh the queen covered it up
what would I don't know in the current system
you know there are no repercussions nothing gets
out but but also I mean you can see yeah yeah
in an Empire that right now is already you
know a victim of infighting and is you know
I forget the direct quote now but yeah like you
know A House Divided is you know is weak and
prone to fall and that could easily like with
all the stuff surrounding rhaenyra and all the
things we saw the people in the streets saying
a few episodes back you know this could easily
taint and tarnish yeah like I bet because we got
aegon with the prophecy slipped to Allison at the
end I imagined some kind of foisting of his status
will come out of that but then if this information
is also out that you know this was covered up
and this is what he did then they can sow those
seeds of Deceit among the people too so I don't
know it all it all translates into a mess for
me yeah it'll just become an even Messier even
more disgusting situation than it already is
and that's the thing like this episode has that
as that the show does but there are constant big
reminders of like oh yeah this is not a world
where the truth sets anyone free well sure just
keeps delivering guys hey um what did you think
about this episode leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that Bell leave a like
and um I'll send this with a patreon
aniso liver now Anisa the real rejects has been
predominantly men this entire time but one day
we'll pass I'll go John will go I guess you would
assume maybe Coy's next in line to take over then
but no we've decided that you will be Queen
of the reject Nation you will inherit the real
rejects Channel now I know you don't film videos
I know you don't edit I know you don't know how to
make thumbnails you know you don't understand
SEO I know there's a lot you don't understand
well that's why it's going to burn at the ground
in your hands I'm not gonna lie I have zero faith
that you're going to be able to keep this boat
steady you are not the song of ice and fire yet
you will be blamed entirely for the downfall of
the real Rejects and I think just as a woman you
should inherently have the strength to uh take on
unfair blame so Anisa you are the perfect victim
of the circumstance that we're dealing for you
right now and you have no say in the matter no
say no oh my God what and if anybody tries to
put koi on the the Iron Throne of the region
yeah oh my God in fact we should just kill it
the next time he comes in just to make sure
yeah and we have to kill Sally he thinks he's
having G fuel when he comes here slowly poisoning
dude milk of the poppy on koi sonisa I would say
I'm sorry but hey that's just the world we live in
just get used to it thank you
for being here for like years